okay we're here to play a truther spice
I'm nervous I'm scared I'm pretty good
with spicy food a little about the side
of mean I think creeps up that and I
stay strong this one she's being very
modest she's did like five videos
already and she does not react to any
heat me any other hand I'll probably buy
the crime I can do that what is the most
illegal thing you've ever gotten away
with I've done a lot of illegal things
in my day like as a child I definitely
still want some candy from a store that
was definitely really bad bad me well
you survived that when you don't have to
take a shot I real spicy chocolate spice
for you out of here so I'm praying as
you like it come on I see chocolate
spicy chocolate okay this is like will
the four chambers spicy like we go thy
spice spice mix spice I'm nervous more
so for the question for the spice do you
think you'll do you think you're married
the person you are currently dating yo
what are you trying to do you in yes
[Music]
schloss by small spicy peanuts the ghost
pepper nuts I was on it pretty bad you
got a solution
yeah I might not even eat it I'm a very
truthful person I don't really like that
much you don't eat this Oh show me the
sixteenth photo in your camera roll well
let me actually I don't think that's
fair I can't look you know okay I'll go
big if I'm gonna go I'm gonna go big you
don't go through your photos I'm not
absolutely I don't know what I got whoo
yeah whoo hell that's a lot heart I said
to this mom let's have a go big yeah you
did spicy spicy spicy chocolate spicy
chocolate oh yes this look like hell
yeah so yes eat the spicy sucker the toe
of Satan that's not sassy a girl I don't
know have you slept with
that's how do people I change the answer
how do you have you slept in my wife
fine you will never your lifetime okay
is it a lick no no it's like you got to
eat this until we stop please not true
how about this how about how about you
got to eat it oh it tastes like cinnamon
that's what that's what the Satan tose
taste like mm-hmm
I've only samosas tasty tasty
[Music]
this is hot whoo is it hot I mean but
then is it gonna be interesting you know
like I don't know there's gonna be that
interesting because movies what is your
true body count you didn't feed another
thing I'll have to uncover my own
question oh well I could give you I
could give you a real answer is it that
hot is that hot my real answer to that I
don't know that's a legit answer Bob
Hart I need something go I'm gonna lose
it really is it that crazy I don't want
to eat this
yeah or ice cube that I am not even
though yeah see this I mean this I said
I don't know what I just don't know I
want a ballpark is that bad yeah I think
I really don't want to eat this I want
you to go through this what ice thank
you listen there's got to be serious
destiny has done like my videos and has
been flawless
there's got to be real I don't want to
go through what you just went through oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay okay
oh how that were cool there yo
no kidding I bet it'll catch you it's
not that you're a baby yeah that was
hell
I was absolutely Oh Rasmus that's what
Satan tote a sight for sure
personally oh you're over-exaggerating
know at the end of it without me the
table who is the person you pretend to
like but actually don't describe your
relationship with this person and I want
a government name a name I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna do that eat the chocolate
babe eat the chocolate yeah there's my
breathe yeah
I just swallow there's no his eyes to it
yeah you right Oh mmm hey my throat
already I'm good honesty okay yeah I'm
fine
I smell it on your breath yeah I talk
those real ooh
have you ever sent a spicy photo of
yourself is that reading thing who was
it - it was it okay what the hell you
like I've never had sext because that
could end up literally anywhere destiny
you're a one time you know I was like
I'm gonna send you sexy on a snapchat
cuz I know it'll go away and I'll know
if you save it and I accidentally sent
it to dr. Miami the plastic surgeon
my body so I mean you could have just
been like you know she wants a consult
I don't know you never got back to me
final thought is this was tracking you
should never do this it's pretty bad
like this was hmm this is bad I don't
recommend this for anybody some things
just can't tell the truth about Oh got
to take the spice I can handle spice
pretty well but this sucker I almost ran
up on the stage I will not be doing this
again I've tapped out I've hit my spicy
maximum
[Music]
you